C'est un endroit que Danielya
connaît trop bien. Son bunker
personnel, où elle se réfugie
lors des alertes de plus en plus
fréquentes au raid aérien.
Elle est de retour
chez elle depuis peu après
deux semaines d'exil en Pologne.
Elle a inscrit ses filles
de 15 et 17 ans à l'école
Cracovie, puis elle a écouté
son coeur qui lui disait
de rentrer en Ukraine.
En prenant le thé avec elle,
ne lui dites pas qu'elle a posé
un geste courageux.
Elle veut simplement aider les
réfugiés qui ont besoin d'aide,
trouver du renfort pour les
bénévoles à bout de souffle, en
plus de poursuivre son travail
habituel d'orthodontiste.
Svitlana aussi a senti l'appel
de la patrie en elle, une fois
sa mère et sa fille de 6 ans,
Victoria, bien en sécurité
et à l'abri à Cracovie,
elle est revenue à Lviv.
Coup du hasard sur le chemin
du retour, on lui a demandé
de diriger le département
des communications de Lviv
en temps de guerre.
Le coup d'éclat des poussettes
vides pour représenter la
centaine d'enfants ukrainiens
morts depuis l'invasion russe
a fait le tour du monde.
C'est une idée de Svitlana.
Elle germait dans sa tête
depuis quelques semaines.
Svitlana voulait montrer l'ampleur
du désastre causé par l'invasion
et forcer les puissances
mondiale à appuyer l'Ukraine.
Même si elle dit qu'il
n'y a aucune place à l émotion
et qu'elle doit se dédier
entièrement à son pays,
Svitlana nous fait écouter
un message de sa fille,
l'implorant de la retrouver
rapidement.
Elle reçoit 50 messages
par jour de sa petite Victoria.
Des messages difficiles pour
le coeur d'une mère, aussi
dédiée à une cause soit-elle.
Dans le sous-sol de Danielya,
les marques des heures passées
dans son abri anti-bombes.
Un rappel, selon elle, que
la guerre se poursuit et que
son pays a besoin d'elle.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Lviv, en Ukraine.